hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar
efficiency to confidence with high
resolution accurate mass spectrometers
analyzing igf-1 i am jennifer woods of
labrutz and i'll be your moderator for
today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by thermo fisher scientific
to learn more visit thermofisher.com
let's get started before we begin i
would like to remind everyone that this
event is interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation to do so
simply type them into the ask a question
box and click send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation click on the support
tab
found at the top right of the
presentation window or report your
problem by clicking on the ask a
question box located on the far
left of your screen this presentation is
educational and thus
offers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located at the top
right of the presentation window and
follow the process to obtain your
credits
i now present today's speaker tony mouse
clinical development associate mayo
clinic
clinical mass spectrometry lab and
clinical forensic and toxicology lab
for a complete biography on our speaker
please visit the biography tab
at the top of your screen tony you may
now begin your presentation
hello everyone i'm tony mouse of the
clinical mass spectrometry development
lab here at mayo clinic
and i'm going to talk today about
quantitation of igf-1
and identification of variants
igf-1 variance and quantitation of those
variants
um so to start just want to give a brief
introduction to the molecule of interest
here
igf-1 the this is uh the image of igf-1
um it has a 70 amino acid polypeptide
with three disulfide bonds like insulin
hence the name
insulin-like growth factor it's about
7.6 kilodalton
so uh just a little bit of background as
to why this is important enough such
great clinical interest
the primary use of it is diagnosis of
growth as
access sticks function it's used in
conjunction
with growth hormone measurements it
provides certain
advantages over growth hormone
measurements we get a lot of
a lot of our patients are repeat samples
where we are monitoring the implications
of their treatment
so consistency is of the utmost
importance when we're doing this
testing and that is a lot of the impetus
as to why we went with mass spectrometry
over
other techniques which we'll talk about
in greater detail in
future slides so i just wanted to uh
to kind of compare and contrast the
benefits
of grow igf over growth hormone
measurements
it's really captured in this very nice
figure
this was this figure was generated from
seven pediatric patients
so it was a relatively small sample set
but it really
this figure really captures the essence
of the
the general issue for endocrinologists
and that's uh
that growth hormone fluctuates to a much
greater extent
than igf-1 so growth hormone is in the
lower right-hand corner
total igf-1 which is what we are
measuring and discussing today
is in the upper right hand corner and
relatively speaking igf-1 is much more
constant throughout the course of the
day
as relative to growth hormone
so that's the advantage of measuring
growth hormone
igf overgrowth hormone they're both used
as
in complementary roles in the clinical
setting
but igf-1 is definitely of great value
to the clinician
historically igf-1 measurements have
been
measured almost exclusively by amino
assay
that but of course the amino acids have
certain
limitations that that mass spectrometry
can overcome
so that is why uh mass spectrometer is
becoming more of an emerging technique
for measurement of igf-1 along with
other polyp
similar size polypeptides the
the primary issues with immunoassays
are compromised agreement between
different immunoassays
we see this all the time with igf-1 and
other amino acids
manufacturer to manufacturer differences
are significant
they often don't agree very well and
then
as we'll discuss in great detail in the
following slide the really the the big
reason
we at mayo clinic decided to go away
from igf-1 immunoassays was lots a lot
reagent inconsistency
we will discuss that in greater detail
and then of course with immunoassays the
a major concern is interference from
a myriad of substances that
mass spectrometer just overcomes these
using based on the
greater specificity of the technique and
then
the final bullet point here i don't even
think was fully appreciated
until mass spectrometry became a more
viable technique for measurement of
igf-1
because immunoassays all amino acids
will detect variants to a different
degree maybe they won't detect them at
all
it's very difficult without doing
studying each individual variant to
understand the extent to which
the immunoassay detects the variant of
interest
so it was really inconsistent detection
of the variance
which mass spectrometry is well suited
for detection of these variants
so just uh a little background as to
what
spurred us to create a mass spectrometry
test for igf-1
uh this this is a paper a group of mayo
published in
2013 this figure is out of that and
the gray uh the lighter gray is below
the
the percent in this figure so we have
two sites here a
is mayo clinic b is the university of
virginia
the lighter gray is the uh percentage
in this figure is the percentage of
patients below nor below the reference
interval
and the the black is the percentage of
patients above the reference interval
and what is obviously concerning is the
inconsistent nature
and the fact that there's a general
trend in the number of patients above
and below
the reference interval and given
what i stated at the beginning that a
lot of the patients that are
receiving igf-1 results are being
monitored
to make decisions about their treatment
this inconsistency is something that
really we couldn't live with
the other big issue here is that so this
is both of these are using the same
manufacturer
you could see the spikes or
inconsistencies don't even correlate
from site to site
likely because of the use of different
reagent lots
and if you're not timed up and using the
same reagent lot
you won't even agree despite the fact
that
um you're using the same manufacturer
and test
you may not agree at any given time so
based on these results
at that time it was decided that we
would go after
a mass spectrometry based test and
just i would just like to go through
some just general
these are the most high level possible
things we consider whenever we're
developing a test for any polypeptide
protein
we cut this is the first question we
always ask it i think
everyone asks do we want to measure it
intact or are we going to digest it
they're just at the high level the
things we're considering
of course the clinical field has
historically been
very triple quad-centric and triptych
digest is
more amiable to triple quad analysis
that's not to say like igf-1 can't be
measured on a triple quad but given the
myriad of fragmentation sites and the
size of the molecule
really is sub-optimal the other
big advantage of tryptic digestion is
the
improved sensitivity relative to impact
measurement
in almost every case you're going to be
more sensitive at the peptide level the
tryptopic peptide level than you are
going to be at the
intact larger molecule level but the
biggest
issue from in a clinical lab with
tryptic digestion
is the time consuming nature of the
digestion and the labor required
a little easier when you have some
graduate students to do the digestion
for you but
we're relying on lab tax and we're
trying to get results out as quickly as
possible
so we prefer to avoid the digestion
whenever possible
the other issue with triptych digest is
the limited
information you're going to get on
variance or the challenges with
analyzing variants you're obviously
going to have to add
uh target a different like if you were
using a triple quad for example
you would have to add a
a fragment precursor ion fragment
transition
for every single variant you wanted to
monitor on your
triple quad and you would have to add
multiple peptides in addition to the
different fragments and precursor ions
that could form
if you're going to consider a number of
variants
it really becomes unwieldy in a short
time so
it's not impossible but it's less than
ideal
so the um the intact measurement here
this slide
is really just the inverse of what i
said for tryptic digest
but what led us to the intact
measurement is that um really
like the issue of sensitivity is a major
turn off in terms of intact measurement
well that's not significant in this case
for igf-1
just in the sense that the normal ranges
are are at a level suitable for
measurement
at the intact level there really isn't a
clinical need to go
lower than what can be measured at a
reasonable
with reasonable ease at the intact level
the other issue that i pointed out with
intact measurement
is sub-optimal for triple quad analysis
well
conveniently and based on large amounts
of planning
we we received or we purchased high
resolution instruments
at the same time as we were moving
towards igf-1
so we we overcame that issue by
purchasing the appropriate
instrumentation
and so we have in our lab multiple
qe pluses so all of our routine
instruments are
qe pluses in addition to the
sensitivity and resolution benefits that
this platform provides over
competitor high resolution instruments
the real selling point
for us was uh what is pictured in these
in in this image is the four plex lc
anyone who is used to the clinical lab
is used to using these uh multi-channel
lcs to improve throughput
the real benefit that the thermal
platform provides that others do not
it's the only manufacturer that
conveniently couples their high
resolution instrument
to these multi-channel lc's so in
addition to the benefits just at the
mass spectrometry level
really what sold us was the use of these
multiplex lcs
and i'll go through the benefits of
using those in greater detail
in one moment
so just a very brief um summary of the
sample preparation and i don't have to
be
uh elongate this because it's very very
simple which is part of what makes this
test
brilliant um the sample preparation we
only require 100 microliters of sample
it's not particularly sensitivity
challenge so we don't need
need a bunch of serum to do this the
this sample is
theorem and then 25 microliters of
internal standard which is an n15
labeled internal standard purchased from
prospect
simply the next step is to dissociate
the binding proteins
from the target igf-1 uh the vast
majority of igf-1
in the circulating form is bound to
binding proteins
so we use acid to dissociate the binding
proteins
and then ethanol precipitates the
larger proteins in this serum
and leaves the smaller polypeptides such
as igf-1 in solution
so the precipitation is further
facilitated with
a neutralization and then incubated at
-20 for 30 minutes
and then this is simply centrifuge and
to get the pallet to fully form at the
bottom and then we just
inject the supernatant so this is done
in a 96 wall plate
and we don't process any further than
that we just do all the
this entire process which is essentially
a crash
in the plate spin it to the bottom and
then we have the auto sampler
needle height at the correct position
to just pull up the supernatant without
any of the palette and there's no
further processing necessary
so uh we really like this workflow it's
as you could see extremely inexpensive
and really fast so it's it's very
suitable for a high throughput clinical
lab
the lc method i'd like to discuss this
in in some detail just in case for those
who aren't familiar with the use of
these
tlx lc systems because it's a little
different than like a research
trap and a loot technique
provides certain advantages so the um
the way this is done is that 40
microliters of sample
is injected onto a c12 cartridge
with the loading pump so the loading
pumps load that sample onto a c12
cartridge and it is washed at high
or at high percent a low percent b for
a few minutes of two three minutes on
average generally
um just to further clean up the sample
and get rid of these the salts these
sorts of things
that as the sample prep i outlined in
the previous slide is not
particularly extensive additional
cleanup on
on the instrument is necessary to
protect the analytical column and
improve the column life
so that is done at this with the loading
pumps
washing the c12 cartridge so then uh
when after it has been a prop properly
washed
online the uh sample is eluded off
the c12 with 40 percent organic
and it's teed in as opposed to a
traditional what i think of as a
traditional trap and a loot where the
the valve switches then it goes in line
with the column here it's
teed in and so the elusion off the c12
is at a flow rate of 0.15 mils a minute
40 b and the
uh eluting pump is teed in at 0.35 mils
a minute
and uh at two percent a and that's
effectively mixed and the resulting
solution is
well under twenty percent b and allows
for retention on the c18
column the uh aleutian the gradient
is then seen below that and so
effectively it
starts so uh it's at low a
at the beginning and then it is jumped
up when the
sample has been properly loaded onto the
hplc column
and then there's a gradient from 23 and
a half
percent b to 40 percent b over the
course of about
three or four minutes that's where the
peptide separation occurs and within
that
gradient window is when the mass
spectrometry analysis
occurs but we're only putting it into
the mass spectrometer for 1.25 minutes
that's the acquisition time for each
sample
and then at that time
outside for that time everything else is
going to waste which protects the
mass spectrometer from getting
dirty and the uh
um and while so that allows for greater
throughput
because uh the acquisition time is only
1.25 minutes the total method time is
just under 10 minutes
but we're getting four done in that
under 10 minutes due to the
multi-channel
lc so at any given time
approximately one column is or one
channel is going into
the mass spectrometer and
then in the background the other columns
are being loaded
washed eluded so it really improves the
throughput
of the sample acquisition
which brings us to the mass spectrometry
analysis
after lc separation
the way we do this so this is all done
using full scan ms quantitation so there
is no
fragmentation used to produce our
quantitative results in this test
which is a little bit different than
much of the testing done in the clinical
field especially not
including in our lab it's almost all
done using mrm techniques
well this is done at the precursor ion
level
so we're scanning from
925 to 1145
we use the resolution setting of 70 000
at
m over z 200 on honor instrument that
translates to a
transient time of 256 milliseconds
when the quantitative analysis is done
we're only doing
full scan ms there is no msms or other
analysis components that would require
duty cycles so this is
not an issue it's just ms scanning
repetitively over and over
so we we did have a bit of a conundrum
just
in the way this has been historically
done in our lab
typically we have at least we have a
quantum
quantifying ion and then at least one
qualifying fragment
that we confirm matches the
initial quantitation ions so there's
we're always monitoring at least
two fragments from the parent and we
assure that those match
prior to reporting out the results to
the patient
in this case uh we're obviously not
fragmenting so
we couldn't monitor alternative
fragments so the way
we have chosen to do this is by
monitoring the plus seven
and the plus h charge states so we use
the the plus seven charge state as the
quantifying ion
and the plus eight short straight as the
charge state as the qualifying ion and
so
uh we quantitate the five biggest
isotopes
in both the plus seven and the plus
eight charge state of igf-1
and we do the same in the internal
standard so you can see in this
single scan window from 925 to 1145
we're capturing the plus eight charge
state and the plus seven charge save for
both
the target and the internal standard so
as opposed to a triple quad which would
require four different cycles for this
we're getting all of that in one which
is really an advantage
of the technique so i just kind of
wanted to show what this looked like
on the bench for our technologists so uh
in the upper left hand corner there
there's a window where you can see you'd
select
that you can view your 1093 quant
which is the plus seven charge state the
qual
as it is called which is the plus eight
charge state
and the uh in the the way this is
displayed to the technologist
uh we usually put although it's really
flexible the software is really flexible
in what you view
and how you view it we typically have
the analyte on the lower left hand which
is really just the sum of the five
biggest isotopes of wild type ifgf1
approximately 1093 and then on the
lower or really the center um bottom
is the internal standard and then the
calibration curve can be seen on the
right although
there's a drop down right there which
allows you to select different
things um to view such as spectra
or fragment confirmation if that is
what is being used and we will show a an
example of that
later
based on the clinical indication
that the igf-1 a70t
and a67t variants are not
exhibiting negative implications for the
patients based on their high frequency
and our understanding of the clinical
picture
we made the decision to sum
the two results when reporting of the
a70t and the a67t
to the wild type igf-1 result
to yield what we believe is a fully
functional
igf-1 result or total igf-1 result
for the patient so that we accurately
reflect what is
fully functional in
circulating within the patient so that
was our goal
and so when we initially began doing
that we obviously generated a
calibration curve but there is
no reference material for the
variance and so we were using
polypeptides from prospect that
had the amino acid substitution and
they're very very good products but they
are not intended to be reference
materials
we were having issues with the results
disagreeing
because of the difficulty in maintaining
and
obtaining proper calibration material
so to overcome this we created
this is our validation data
proving that using the wild type
1093 curve is equivalent to
using the variant calibrator
so in in these data set
we got our our criteria was a slope
within 10 percent
of one and then an r squared greater
than 0.99
you can see the r squared is very very
good and there is
small evidence of a slight bias now it
is
uh it was never conclusively determined
whether
this bias is truly a result of the
difference in the amino acid
change or whether that's an indication
of
incompatible calibrators or calibrators
that are not properly aligned
we did not explore that to that extent
but what we did prove
we felt was that it was certainly viable
to quantitate the known variance
off of the wild type igf-1 calibration
curve
and because we have a solid reference
material and it decreases the labor
required in our lab of maintaining
multiple calibration curves
we made the decision going forward to
only
create a calibration curve of the 1093
and quantitate
the the
detected variants that are believed to
be functional
off of that calibration curve and this
has been
uh in addition to this initial
validation this has proven viable over
time
as the results almost always match very
well like well within 10 percent
between observed variance in the
heterozygous patient
and the wild type igf-1
so uh we we had we were being very
successful in quantitative igf-1
and uh the most frequent variants
which are the a67 and a70 t variants
but uh in in looking closer at the
literature
we ran into an issue with our current
our methodologies at the time and that's
that
our technique at the time was unable to
confidently differentiate between a67
and a7t which
are likely to be fully functional and
the known
pathogenic v 44 m variant
there is literature evidence that
strongly suggests that the v-44m
is not functional and so we
were running the risk or we were
concerned about the potential
of reporting out v44m concentration as
fully functional
when it in fact if if confirmed to be
v44m
is certainly non-functional
the issue as you can see in this
overlapping theoretical spectrum
is that the isotopic distributions
overlap to a great extent
and uh differentiating them by
laboratory technologists at a bench with
limited experience in interpretation of
mass spectra
is challenging so we had to come up with
a reliable methodology
to overcome that just as an example
these are some spectra produced by trace
finder
so in trace finder it is not capable of
averaging at this time
and so the spectra that the text would
would look at
in this case would be not averaged and
these are the
signals so the a67 a70t
spectrum on top is certainly from a
lower concentration sample
and you can see that the distribution
does not reflect theoretical at all
it doesn't align with what we would
expect and it's very very difficult to
interpret which of these signals
is the monoisotopic key
the v44m signal
or at the bottom is much clearer and
clearly of higher abundance but is still
difficult especially for someone who's
not used to interpreting mass spectra to
confidently identify
the uh mono isotopic peak
and i didn't want to make these
decisions
solely based on the mono isotopic peak i
wanted to use the totality of the
isotopic distribution to do this one
if you look at the distribution you can
clearly see clearly differentiate
between the two
but looking at any single isotope it's
very difficult so
we wanted to use the totality of the
distribution
to differentiate between the two
this is a great table which was recently
published by a group from quest
and uh this is very interesting it um
not all of the variants shown here
were detected in their study but it does
show the
high frequency of variants which have
isotopic distributions centered about
1097 or 1098 uh there
the the point i'm trying to get at is
that there are in addition to
the a70t a67t variants that
we knew overlapped with v44m they're
actually a myriad of other
potential variants that overlap
would have distributions that overlap
with the relatively frequent a67 and
a70t
variants so we needed a precise method
at the ms level to differentiate and
confidently
distinguish between the what we believe
or what we're confident in is high
frequency variance
a67 and a70t which we want to report out
as functional versus the myriad of other
possibilities many of which such as the
v17 and v44m
are known to be pathogenic
so our technique to overcome
this issue and to confidently identify
the variance at the ms level
we wanted to stick if we could to the ms
level because that's where all our
quantitation was done and rather than
adding an msms component to the method
at the easiest solution was to
come up with a methodology based on the
isotopic distribution
so the way we have done this the
laboratory technologist opens up the
spectrum or the chromatogram excuse me
in the excalibur software
and they average across the
chromatographic peak
so they just highlight across to get an
average mass spectrum
which really improves the signal to
noise of the spectrum it makes a lot
more confident in the isotopic
distribution
so they generally average about 30 scans
there's really no bad way to do this
it's very robust it's not
particularly dependent on the way the
technologist highlights the peak as long
as they get over 10 scans which is very
easy
it'll be just fine so um that
spectral peak list is then exported to
an excel macro
and all of this uh work is done in the
macro in a matter of seconds
and so what is done in the macro is the
peak list
is input and it eliminates
signals that are greater than 0.01 from
theoretical
from the theoretical signal of a67 or
a70t that would have the same
theoretical
ms mass precursor mass so we're just
eliminating the noise the irrelevant
signals
or limiting to only the
signals of interest so i chose 0.01 is
approximately
10 ppm at this m over z
um after the irrelevant signals
have been eliminated we get a list of
depending on the
signal within the analyte it's about 14
isotopes that are used to calculate the
center of mass
and so the this formula which we adapted
from
just general physics center of mass
calculations
is then applied and yields a center of
mass
for the isotopic distribution and so we
get
it's effectively an m over z value
of the center of mass of the isotopic
distribution
so in this example spectrum which is an
a67 or a70t
uh we got a center of mass of 1097.95
once the formula was applied to the
filtered peak list
we then we created a confidence interval
based on 30 replica
measurements over the course of 10 days
we used that those measurements to
create a confidence interval
we went with plus or minus 4 standard
deviations
that confidence interval is then applied
to the
center of mass and the
to yield and identification
so this is uh some example spectra
um overlapping spectra from the two
targets of interest um so you can see
so when we did the validation the 30
replicates over 10 days
we performed a simple t-test and the
p-value from that t-test was
6.9 times 10 to the minus 68. so we were
very confident that we were
getting statistically distinguishable
results we got
26.8 pooled standard deviations between
the means
which was really the impetus to go with
a plus or minus 4
uh standard deviation confidence
interval in assigning the
identifications we had a few standard
deviations to give so we were very
conservative
so that we didn't miss anything so you
can see
the overlapping distribution what's
plotted here is
average spectra not single scan spectrum
so that you get a pretty nice
distribution
and the red line is the resulting center
of mass
and you can see that they're very easily
distinguished
between one another in statistical terms
the center of mass has proven very very
precise
uh which i attribute to both the power
of averaging the spectra
and the power of using the totality of
the distribution
and when you add those two factors
together we get very very powerful
measurements
that are proven very robust in the
routine setting so the
validation of this methodology occurred
over 200 samples
we used over 200 samples to do that
validation and then in routine use
it has proven very useful
it has never failed to my knowledge
we have always aligned with sequencing
results the only exception was one time
there was a contamination
contaminating ion right in the middle of
the distribution
and i looked at the spectrum and
eliminated that
peak from the peak list because it was
distorting the center of mass
calculation and once that signal signal
was
eliminated the center of mass once again
aligned with the appropriate result
so it is proven very robust
now an alternative completely viable
solution
would be to differentiate these variants
at the ms
ms level and so we developed a scheme to
also do that
we wanted to compare and contrast the
benefits
of the two different methodologies
so we developed this scheme you can see
here with specific fragments that are
useful
for differentiating between known
variants
this uh is not particularly useful
in context of completely unknowns
in many cases but we have designed the
scheme in the context of known variants
so if you look at the msms spectra you
really don't get a
great sequence coverage so this is the
msms vectors that are being shown are
just simple
injections of the supernatant that was
used to gain the
to get the quantitative measurements as
discussed at the beginning so there's no
reduction
calculation being done here this is just
injection of that supernatant
and when you don't reduce the disulfide
bonds your msms spectrum is very
c-terminal-centric
and your sequence coverage is very bad
so you're generally reserved
to basically the last five y and b
ions b 65 through 70 and y
five through y one um
occasionally on a really good day i'll
get like a b62 but it's relatively rare
so the
sequence coverage leaves something to be
desired for certain
the um but it just so happens
we really got lucky in terms of nature
here
that the most common amino acid
substitutions
are at the a67 and a
70 positions where they substitute 239
and based on that substitution we're
able to conclusively determine
the location and type of substitution
using only those five y and b ions
so it's very fortunate that we can fully
characterize the most common variants
using only five ions and very poor
sequence coverage
so this allowed us in the routine
setting to easily differentiate
easily identify confidently a67
and a70t and differentiate them from
v to m substitutions
so what this looks like in practice this
trace finder enables us to do that
and so what is done for the varying
patients is they
all vary in patients are currently being
ran through the center of mass algorithm
and undergo msms analysis and so the way
we have this
set up is we have the target fragments
in
us programmed into tracefinder and it
above a certain signal to noise
threshold it gives a green flag
that those fragments were detected and
the
technologist uses the minimum number of
fragments required
which we designed so that it allowed for
confident differentiation
from the other known variants
to conclusively determine the identity
of a67 and a70 t variants and
differentiate them from the v to m
variants which was really the
initial goal to differentiate the
believed functional variance from the
non-functional variance
so i wanted to show this example in some
detail
this is a an a67t patient we know that
because
the um msms spectra here
yields all the fragments including the
very c-terminal
fragments which would allow for
differentiation of the a70t
and a617t in contrast here
so this is the a7dt spectrum
and we still detect the same y5 ion that
503 is detected
that that would be a shared ion between
the a67 and the a70t
but the smaller fragment ions were not
detected
which conclusively determines the
identity of this particular patient the
a67t
not a 70t and then just as an example
this is what
the the technologist would see if they
looked at v44m for
this patient there's absolutely no
fragments detected that would indicate
v44m
and then we also keep our eye out for
r36q
given that there's strong literature
evidence that that
peptide is also non-functional that
variant is non-functional
we have never detected or found an r36q
patient
but we are constantly monitoring for our
36q
so this scheme
really has some limitations uh it as
i've described earlier it really only
works in the context of known variants
and uh at initially when we began this
we
were focused almost exclusively on the
r36q and v44m
variants based on their presence in the
literature and the known pathogenity
based on literature publications and the
much more
frequent a67 a70 te patients which are
believed to be fully functional
so we were able to easily differentiate
between
those four but the sequence coverage
really
imposed an upper limit on the
characterization we could do
and as we began more fully validating
and characterizing these variant
patients
we began seeing an another variant with
relatively high frequency these are the
a to v
variants so we begin detecting a lot of
i shouldn't say a lot so
uh they're at similar frequencies as the
v44 amp
um so i will go through the frequency of
all the variants detected on the last
slide
so the what we're noticing is we're
getting these
center of masses that were 1097.7
or so which is shifted farther to lower
m over z
than the other two variants we have
targeted in the past
and at first we we did not have genetic
information
on these patients and we were left to
try to determine the identity
of these previously unknown variants
um so uh we
uh first thing we did was perform msms
analysis
and we in the case of an a67v
similar to the a6070 we're able to
easily
identify the location
of the substitution and the nature of
the substitution because the
msms spectrum is so c terminal centric
we're easily able to determine the exact
location of that
a67 substitution
the challenge arose when we were
characterizing these
in the context of unknown variants
we were getting some that were
conclusively not a 67
substitutions but we were unable to
differentiate and locate the
location of the substitution given the
poor msms spectrum coverage
the fragment ion coverage so uh this is
a polyfen
output on i just in the
to help us understand or at least give
initial indications on the functionality
of these
substitutions so we do use this as a
guide but we certainly don't
base patient results on this but
it was interesting that the a67v was
quite possibly functional whereas the
a60
the other potential substitutions were
non-functional so we wanted to be able
to just
conclusively determine the position of
the substitution
um so to do this uh to overcome the
limitations that we were observing
on our qe pluses
we used um some collaborator instruments
here
at the mayo clinic so dr alkalish pandy
in his hat lab has a fusion lumos
a mass spectrometer capable of uvpd etd
and pretty much anything else you can
dream up of up it's very powerful
instrument
so we worked with our collaborators to
to perform alternative msms techniques
to try to
improve the sequence coverage we didn't
like being reliant
on genetic sequencing so we wanted to
overcome that limitation
and so just as an example this is the
a38v variant so we're we use the
what we know now is the a38v variant
as the model system to try to determine
the location of the substitution
and so the a38
the patient aligns with the a67 the a70t
if you don't use reduction in alkylation
you just do msms
the spectrum is exactly as i described
previously
very c terminal centric very limited
sequence coverage
if you simply reduce and alkylate that
polypeptide uh the c terminal the
coverage
switch is to the n terminal so you begin
to get
small uh b ions
in addition to a few of the
uh small y ions that were detected with
ouch reduction inoculation but you're
still not getting anywhere near
the sequence coverage you would like to
observe and we're not probing the center
of the molecule in any way
we then used epd we
did not get spectacular results for this
particular polypeptide with
just etd but we are beginning to get
some sequence coverage in the middle of
the molecule
hcd was not particularly fruitful
either we got very similar fragments as
we were getting
with just hcd
the real powerful techniques for this
particular analysis
was et were etc id and
uvpd so this is the etcd
the lower energy collision spectrum
and in this case uh we got really
pretty good sequence coverage um and we
really got a lot in the center of the
molecule and the
uh red amino acid shown here is the
location which we did
later determined based on sequencing to
be a 38v
genetic sequencing uh to be a38v
based on this etc id spectrum we were
able to conclusively determine the
location of the substitution
uh uvpd also provided additional um
cleavages uh in the center of the
molecule and uh
so happens that in this particular
spectrum we were able to
definitely exactly identify the location
of
the substitution in the a38v patient
we also got a number of very interesting
fragments uh
we got ace b
c v we also got capital y this is not
a typo i have small y
and capital y ions in this figure uh
capital y we adopted the nomenclature
from protein prospector
and that's a a y ion minus two
so to differentiate between those two so
that is a unique fragmentation
and so uh in this reconstructed msms
spectrum
i have filtered out all the irrelevant
signals just to make it a little more
aesthetically pleasing
and you can really see the complementary
nature of all these techniques
and the power of
these techniques to conclusively
identify without sequencing
the location of the amino acid
substitution now this was done on a
patient sample with a relatively low
circulating concentration it was
only about as i recall about 100
nanograms per mil
and so at very relevant concentrations
we were able to conclusively determine
the location of the substitution
and it looks promising that we could
determine the location
of almost any amino acid substitution
using these techniques
so we really reduced our reliance on
genetic sequencing and
made a boon for msms techniques
independent of genetic sequencing
so i would just like to finish with the
summary of all of our results and the
variants we have observed
so we have ran at the time of this study
we had ran 146
000 igf-1 samples we detected variants
and
556 of those samples i would add that
the proportion isn't going to add up to
the
0.6 percent variance that i cited at the
beginning
we have improved our techniques for
detecting the variants and we are now
detecting them at a higher frequency
than we did initially um so of that
those 556 uh detected variants
we you can see the breakdown here so the
vast vast majority of the variants are
of the a67 and a70 t variety
we um which we believe to be fully
functional and we report
out as such we add it to the functional
uh
the wild type igf-1 concentration
and then we get a myriad of other
variants so we detected three v44m
variants in this subset we did get two
homozygous a67t variants
but no homozygous a70 t variants in this
sample set
a v17m we're seeing that with
nearly the same frequency as the v44m
in this relatively small sample set but
these
and then we are seeing these a to v
variants with a frequency that we did
not necessarily expect when we began
analyzing these using our current
techniques and now that we
are expecting them and have added them
to the framework of our
understanding of the variants we're
easily able to identify those
those are not reported out as functional
at this time given the uncertain nature
of the implications of that variant
um then we also detected one
silent mutation which obviously the mass
spectrometer cannot identify
and the ac we had one patient which
exhibited both an a67t and an a70t
in conclusion i would just like to thank
some of my colleagues here uh
dr ravinder singh and dr stefan grebe
are the
directors of our laboratory and oversaw
all this work and i owe a great deal to
them they've been instrumental in my
career development
jenny kemp with is my main partner in
crime and without whom none of this
would be possible
uh she's a great help to me all of this
work and
we worked very hard on this together
dragana assisted us with all the dna
sequencing
and dr santosh renews and dr pandy for
helping us with the msms techniques and
allowing us use of their instrumentation
to do those analyses
i also need to thank all the folks in
the roof clinical mass spectrometry
routine laboratory
as they work very hard and acquire a
great deal of this data and
do a great job monitoring and properly
reporting these variants on a daily
basis
that's all i had thank you very much for
listening
and giving me your time thanks
thank you tony for your informative
presentation we will now start the live
q a portion of the webinar
if you have a question you would like to
ask please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far
left of your screen and we'll answer as
many questions as we have time for
let's get started our first question is
what are some of the other potential
applications of the center of mass
technique
yeah so uh as you can see in the
presentation
in its current form it's a little bit
cumbersome
the workflow is not ideal for high
throughput clinical analysis
but if we can find a way for the
software
to be more amiable to this analysis i
think it would be really powerful
in our targeted uh environment like
one issue that immediately comes to mind
and a different issue
in our lab is we do light chain analysis
of monoclonal antibodies
and if we were able to conveniently do
center mass and confirm the uh isotopic
distribution center of mass
for those molecules it would really help
us separate out interference
on the low end from the polyclonal
background in our target monoclonals
so you think there is great potential
for use of this
this technique or a similar concept in
our targeted
uh testing
and tony can this method be transferred
to a triple quadruple instrument
uh so um it depends on what specific
aspect of the method you're talking
about
um so the center of mass technique if
that is what the the question refers to
uh could certainly be
used on a triple quad uh although with
low resolution you could argue that
just use centroid of the
distribution as the center of mass
and forego the calculation steps so that
portion
could be used on a triple quad given
adequate impetus
the as far as the analysis of the
variance or the quantitation of the igf
is
if that is what the question is
referring to uh i alluded to this
earlier in the presentation and i
just reiterate uh it's not impossible to
or um it's not impossible to
quantitate igf-1 on a triple quad it's
just as you can see in the msms spectra
we were getting large b
ions predominantly and
those are sub optimal for triple quad
analysis so we're just not getting a
variety the variety of or the
convenient transmission of triple quad
fragment ions that would be ideal for
triple quality analysis
so the um that that portion of it
is possible to do on a triple quad it's
just less than ideal
and then the variant analysis could be
done on a triple quad you just have to
add
individual transitions for each
precursor ion
and fragments using an mrn so it would
be cumbersome
but could is possible
great thank you we have time for a few
more questions our next question is what
biomarkers are you planning to
quantitate on in the future
our lab is always interested in a great
deal of molecules there's always more
molecules to target
that we can get to igf binding protein
is one we have talked about targeting
uh insulin analogs is one we're
currently working on extensively
covid peptides is also
being worked on in our lab although it's
challenging for a variety of reasons but
that is
something we're working on
you name it we'll try to quantitate it
we're always
trying to push the boundaries so those
are specific ones we're working on or
interested in but
our interest knows no bounds
thank you tony our last question is by
using multiplexing are you saving time
in your analysis
how many samples are you running a day
so we are certainly uh saving
time so the
lc run time is just under 10 minutes
like nine minutes
and we are able to as opposed to a
traditional lc without multiplexing you
would only get the one sample in the
nine minutes
we're getting four samples done in the
nine minutes
um i'm not sure we are at liberty to
disclose exactly how many samples we're
doing today
but uh the effective run time then is
basically two and a half minutes every
two and a half minutes we're able to
produce a result
for a patient result so
the mo the through the multiplexing is
absolutely necessary for this analysis
if it wasn't for that and we were trying
to run the volumes we currently have
you would consume an entire instrument
all day just trying to do this so that
the multiplexing is absolutely
imperative
looks like we have one more question
come in and i have a we have a few more
minutes so i'm going to ask you one last
question
um we are interested in igf-1 isoforms
have you ever
quantified them by ms
that is not something our group has
explored
certainly interesting i look forward to
hearing your work on that uh that's not
something we
did explore or are looking to explore
our focus continues to be uh
variance so we're constantly on the
lookout for new
variants but iso forms is not
what we're not something we're currently
interested in
thank you tony do you have any final
comments for our audience
no thank you very much to thermo and
webroots for allowing me to do this
and i thank you for your time everyone
who listened
oh thank you again tony for your time
today and for your important research
we would also like to thank lab roots
and our sponsor thermo fisher scientific
for underwriting today's educational
webcast before we go i'd like to thank
the audience for joining us today
and for their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period
will be addressed by the speaker via the
contact information you provided at the
time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand lab
routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
until next time goodbye
you